I think she sort of hated the sort of
babysitting of journalists you know the
idea that you know there would be a
media center in a conflict zone I mean
that would be complete and a themá-- to
her that there was some control over
where you got your stories from and if
she saw a pack of journalists she would
go resolutely in the other direction I
mean there was a famous line when she
said my god I think they're drugging the
journalists because everyone seemed like
they were sort of you know she went in
somewhere where people were waiting for
visas and thought everyone you know
looked like they were kind of drugged
out of their minds you know it was just
sort of waiting and and and stop being
proactive so you know she met Paul and
he was the guy who'd smuggled himself
into Syria by building a boat and that's
what impressed her there's a quote in
the film it's her editor who said she's
seen more war than most soldiers and and
Paul Conroy came from an army background
and the film really does tackle the
subject of PTSD which at the time wasn't
really spoken about in terms of
journalists war reporters war
correspondents it was seen as solely
something that belonged to the Armed
Forces how does this film explore that
and its effect on Marie I think that's
that in the title a private war you know
it's about it's about you know people
who who venture kind of outside of the
pack into the most dangerous places on
earth but it's also about the private
war of mind I think some - sometimes the
lonely moments happen when you're back
at home processing what you've seen and
of course you know that's why what the
foreign correspondents had the
reputation for you know hard drinking
and partying because there's a you know
that's certainly one release but it only
goes takes you so far and ultimately
there's always going to be the time when
you're when the sort of devastation of
all that you've witnessed hits home
please listen to me that it took its
toll on Murray it took its toll on Paul
as well and when you look at her career
in the story she told because the
question she would ask everywhere she
went is why isn't the world here I want
to tell these people's stories so people
will listen so the question I supposed
having inhabited these people's lives do
you feel that it's worth it 100% yeah
yeah and I you know it's still you know
look at Murray lost her life in Syria
Vic what's still happening in Syria
today you know and need more people like
Marie and Paul here willing to go
against the flow to to reveal the truth
of these conflict zones I mean it's
that's you know it's a it's a breed of
journalism that should be heralded and
we think that this movie is a so how
much to to journalism and um you know I
don't think for a minute they would say
it wasn't it wasn't worth it you know
you know and they have the courage to
call out dictators on their lives
memory was the first person to sort of
go on record saying you know this idea
that the Syrian regime is going off of
terrorist gangs as a complete and utter
lie and then you know what happens is
after sort of seven years of conflict
you know a regime can be sort of slowly
rehabilitated and suddenly kind of you
know get back on the international stage
with some respectability and and Jamie
and I she kind of were a bit stunned
sitting here having this interview
because we've just heard that the case
that Murray's sister was bringing
against the Assad regime
went to court and the judge passed
judgment yesterday that the Syrian
regime has been found guilty of
deliberately targeting journalists
deliberately targeting the media center
and are guilty of the direct
assassination of Murry which is a
massive verdict
I mean it's colossal and we've just you
know we've just had that news just about
three minutes ago yeah and you know that
all was born out of the fact that when
Paul Conroy was in the media center in
Homs
he with his military background heard
the pattern of shellfire and said okay
this is there
racketing this is this is we are being
deliberately targeted and we have to
leave right now because they found us do
you think this film will restore faith
in those journalists who are going out
there putting their lives on the line to
shine a light in places in the world
that people can't have easy access to I
hope so I think I think the curious
thing about this film is that it is
uplifting I think I think people think
they're maybe in for a hard challenging
watch and I think the ultimate feeling
is that you feel like you've grown a
little bit but the experience of living
with people like Marie and Paul because
they kind of show that there is so much
more to life if you kind of get out of
your own bubble Marie Colvin would go
everywhere and want to tell people
stories why do you think her story
should be heard on one level I think you
know she wouldn't want to be part of the
story but on another level I think what
minam in our director has cleverly done
is he's put the focus where she would
have wanted it which is on you know the
people she wrote about and he cast
pretty much the entire sort of canvas of
our movie that you know isn't Jamie me
Stanley Tucci and other English actors
who populate the London scenes with with
refugees from various conflict zones
currently living in Jordan so you know
there are people talking in their own
words about their own experiences which
Tully very closely to the articles that
Murray wrote so in a way you know the
biggest close-ups of our film they're
not on me or Jamie they're on you know
the Syrian people that she would have
put the biggest close-up on